when it comes to the films of
Christopher Nolan his characters may
seem straightforward but their stories
and the way he tells them can be
anything but Nolan's filmography is
littered with confusing moments so here
are some explanations to help you
understand that better
Nolan's 1998 debut feature following
centers on a character who calls himself
Bill who is obsessed with following
people than anybody I just wanted to see
where they went what I did bill finds
himself involved in a grander conspiracy
after following a burglar named Tom
throughout the film ill accompanies Cobb
on burglaries and becomes entwined in a
plot involving a woman known as the
blonde and a criminal called the bald
man things get out of hand after bill
ends up killing a man but when he turns
himself in to the police the twist is
revealed Cobb has actually been working
with the bald man and has been planting
evidence throughout the film to set bill
up to take the fall for Cobbs killing at
the blonde she as it turns out has been
blackmailing the bald man
so Cobb kills her everything from the
burglaries to Bill's alias pens the
murder of the blonde on bill it's a
classic noir twist with a bit of Nolan's
personal touch to it
Nolan's 2000 film memento centers on
Leonard Shelby a man who can't form new
memories thanks to an injury sustained
during an assault that left his wife
dead since the assault
he's relied on notes and tattoos to keep
track of the information he feels is
important for him to remember memento
depicts Leonard's hunt for the man
responsible for his wife's death using a
unique framing device starting with the
chronological end of the story then
gradually working its way backward each
scene in the film chronologically
precedes the one which blaze out before
it so that the climax at the end of the
film actually occurs in the middle of
Leonard's revenge story while it's
beginning plays out only in flashback
the nonlinear narrative can be hard to
follow but it's easier to grasp if you
put the story back in chronological
order
Leonard actually found his wife's
attacker and exacted his vengeance long
before mementos chronological starting
points but he quickly forgot did it
happen
afterward Leonard's cohort Teddy began
sending Leonard after a series of other
men he didn't remember so I helped you
start looking again looking for the guy
you already killed upon discovering
Teddy's deception
Leonard leaves himself clues that
indicate that Teddy is the killer and he
eventually shoots him just as he has all
of his previous targets the revelation
completely up ends our understanding of
the story and drastically recolors the
character we've been following in Batman
Begins Bruce Wayne isn't the only man
taking up a mantle bigger than himself
it's also done by one of his greatest
enemies Ra's al Ghul or is it due card
Roz is seemingly killed when Bruce
escapes the League of Shadows in the
film's first act only for his old mentor
Duke Card to resurface later claiming
he's the mastermind and Ra's al Ghul is
merely a smokescreen so does that mean
that there is no real Ra's al Ghul well
not exactly in the Dark Knight Rises
we learned that Ducard has been known as
Ra's al Ghul throughout his life and
operates as the leader of the League of
Shadows however much like Batman Ra's al
Ghul is assembled bigger than one man
Ducard himself notes that the League of
Shadows has been active for centuries it
must always have a leader and that
leader is Ra's al Ghul assemble warned
by many men throughout the ages
including to card The Dark Knight Rises
ends with Bruce Wayne sacrificing his
life to save Gotham City passing on the
mantle of Batman to a new Bearer there's
a funeral and everything but no body to
bury however there's a twist when Alfred
sees Bruce and Catwoman in a European
cafe sometime afterward since Bruce has
died in a nuclear explosion and Alfred
alludes to a similar scene as a fantasy
earlier viewers must wonder whether this
is real or just all in Alfred's head
however all signs point to this being
real and Bruce having escaped death much
of the evidence lies in the revelation
that the bats autopilot was fixed by
Bruce who earlier implied that he had to
fly it manually to get the bomb out of
the city there's no way he wouldn't know
it had been fixed implying that he you
the autopilot to fake his own death in
the prestigious second act ambitious
magician and ji'er becomes obsessed with
replicating a trick performed by his
rival Borden called the transported man
in which Borden seems to teleport
himself from one location to another and
gyr travels to America to meet with
Nikola Tesla who builds him a machine
that allows an G R to perform the same
trick the machine works by creating an
exact copy of the person who enters it
and teleporting one of them a short
distance away while the other is drowned
in a tank underneath the stage it's
never specified whether the machine
transports the original ng R to safety
and drowns the clone or transports the
clone and drowns ng R not even an G or
himself knows which version of himself
gets killed each night since both
versions of ng R believed themselves to
be the real version he has no way of
knowing which is the original and which
is the copy that took courage deployment
every night every time he steps on stage
to perform his version of the
transported man and G R takes his life
in his hands by the end of the prestige
he has no idea whether he's the original
ng R or a copy of a copy of a copy and
neither do we
in the prestige after stealing Borden's
journal and reading that Tesla is the
key to his transported man trick and G R
heads to America to work with Tesla on
what becomes the cloning machine however
as the film reaches its finale we find
out that both Diaries are frauds written
with the intent of misleading each
magician Tesla is merely the key to my
diary no too much trick it makes you
wonder how Angiers collaboration with
Tesla ended up being so fruitful if
Borden simply intended to send ng R on a
wild-goose chase it turns out that
Tesla's invention is an unintended
wrinkle in Gordon's plan his intent was
simply to send an G R overseas looking
for something that wasn't fair wasting
both his time and money in the process
he never dreamed that sending an G R to
Tesla would actually result in Tesla
inventing a machine that would literally
create copies of an G R enabling him to
emulate his trick after all
to help distinguish dream from reality
in Inception each character in Cobbs
crew carries a totem the most prominent
being the spinning top cobb carries with
him at all times if he spins the top and
it collapses he's in the real world if
it never stops
it's a dream the film's ending sees Cobb
reunited with his family he spins the
top but instead of waiting for the
result he rushes to see his children the
top spins and wobbles a tiny bit but the
film cuts to black before it falls until
that moment we have every reason to
believe Cobb is back in reality but is
he really despite the fact that Nolan
himself won't answer definitively there
are context clues that point to cop
being awake the best evidence is the
presence of his children throughout the
film were shown that Cobb can't remember
their faces in the ending he can see
them it may not be a conclusive answer
but it's enough to convince us it's real
one of the most potentially confusing
mechanics in Inception are its kicks or
physical disruptions that wake people
from dreams which factor heavily into
the movie's action-packed third act by
this point in the film Cobb and his team
are three dream levels deep meaning
they're in a dream within a dream within
a dream and it will take a synchronized
series of kicks in all three layers to
jolt them out of it in each level of the
dream time moves more slowly than in the
level above so while hours pass in the
third level only seconds go by in the
first because of this the team
coordinates the kicks by timing them to
a song which can be heard playing at
varying speeds in each of the levels
however in the film's climax Cobb
decides to go even deeper into the dream
to rescue a fallen team member rather
than riding the synchronized kicks back
to wakefulness so while the kicks work
to rouse the other members of the team
Cobb is left behind to continue dreaming
having missed his kick instead he has to
wake himself up from deep within the
dream early on in Nolan's 2014 film
interstellar protagonist Cooper's young
daughter Murph complains of a ghost
haunting a room throwing books around
and seeming to leave her messages it's
later discovered that it's not a ghost
their gravitational anomaly creating
patterns that lead Cooper to a NASA base
which sets him off on his journey
through space
toward the end of the film we finally
find out what the ghost really is after
entering a black hole cooper finds
himself in a place where the dimension
of time is made tangible so he can
understand it using gravity which is the
only thing capable of bridging
dimensions cooper is able to send
messages to Murph in the past including
the data that can save humanity from
destruction
the gravitational anomalies aren't
divine or alien they're Murph's father
defying the boundaries of time and space
to reach his daughter the plot of
interstellar hinges on a wormhole that
was positioned near Saturn forty-eight
years prior to the start of the film but
Amelia brand and her father John never
considered that it might be
naturally-occurring rather they assume
that some form of advanced intelligent
life constructed the wormhole for
altruistic reasons allowing humanity a
chance to survive
following the slow destruction of earth
although they draw no conclusions about
who they might be the implication is
that they are some form of alien life
who've taken a benevolent interest in
humanity however at the end of Endor
stellar when Cooper finds himself inside
a tesseract that allows him to
communicate with his daughter as a child
he realizes that he and the brands have
been wrong about them for the whole
movie they aren't aliens at all instead
they're the humans of the future who
have advanced far beyond the humans at
the present they have learned to
transcend time using gravity which is
how they constructed the wormhole and
how they allowed Cooper to send a
message to his daughter who in turn uses
the information she receives to save
humanity this creates a causal loop in
which humanity is saved by themselves in
the future who in turn only exists
because they were saved in the past the
real events of the 2017 film Dunkirk
took place over the course of a week but
Nolan uses a nonlinear series of
intersecting stories to depict the
events in the film the twisting
narrative maximizes tension but
frustrated some viewers who had trouble
following the chronology done Kirk's
three stories focus on characters
experiencing the historic evacuation on
land in the air and at sea the story
taking place on land
the mole takes place over the course of
one week of the evacuation another
titled the sea takes place over the
course of the last day of the Dunkirk
evacuation finally the air takes place
only over the course of an hour on the
last day of the evacuation Nolan himself
has said he structured it this way to
better depict the experiences and
perspective of the soldiers and citizens
in each story segments check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]